mes filles c'est la raison pour laquelle
tu vas avoir droit à l'interview
paris - comme ça pas loin de 50 ans va
faire une petite île perdue check up
c'est le top
alors la taille c'est toujours un mètre
quatre-vingt ça ça change pas beaucoup
j'en ai vu un peu le poids tu es
toujours à 85
ah non nous aurions bien combien la sq
ont beau jeu c'est paul on n'a rien pour
soigner les dents ça va aller dans bones
ont toujours pas méchant un kit tanagra
gagne origine alors j'en ai deux qui
m'ont fait très creux et quelques années
que j'ai fait changer
et alors depuis et c'est marrant je
marche mieux un pays où il n'y a pas eu
de rejet les cheveux ça va c'est
incroyable rayon on a toutes tes cheveux
fins et très belle chevelure
quel est ton secret
quel est ton secret c'est assez
incroyable
maintenant je suis prof les yeux comment
ils vont tes petits dieux ils vont mal
et où wall parce qu'il écoute et moi ma
chère madame
j'aime beaucoup ce que j'aime beaucoup
vos chaussures et élégante mais quand
même non c'est vrai que dans les yeux ça
va prendre combien tu sais à peu près
les numéros non vous pour se voir mon
enfance entre ceux entre le chien et la
cage mais ça va certainement voyant et
aveugle voilà une activité sexuelle un
ralentissement depuis atteint comme dit
willy à rennes la dernière fois c'était
dans la lah reste au dessus de la
liberté c'est une dame quand même ouais
téléopération toit deux opérations de bt
juteux perreux de la jambe
ouais enfin rien de spécial c'était
varices
ouais et alors ça va maintenant des
pétards et au pea je pense qu'on se pose
plus donc ça m'a écouté
enfin dans le temps prendre le sens mais
les valaisans des ongles son tt arrange
pas les angles non non non je mange les
peaux parce que on peut mettre des
produits dessus donc nous croyons que
les zombies c'est un petit peu dur est
ce que tu as des maladies chroniques non
non ça n'a pas besoin pourquoi j'ai vu
leurs noms mais pour savoir enfin check
up des énergies non à part aux éditeurs
telle est un peu d'énergie ça non mais
dans la tension animateur télé d'abord
sais pas mais qui est un passe-temps
tous s'amusent je suis bien en estive
état des rues des virus non alors par
l'ansa mais maintenant tu es très
cocooning finalement pas ce que je
disais l'autre jour un article le
concernant qui avait été écrit au début
des années 60
ouais et alors ils étaient tous en train
de se déchirer et tout et toi tu étais
avec françoise à noisy-le-sec dans sa
petite maison le petit temps faisait pas
web
le fait que
jardé des gens mal emmerdeur viennent
vous voir donc si on est tranquilles ils
ont rien à raconter
donc ça permet de faire toutes les
conneries view on sent qu on vous
emmerde
est ce important les enfants ils sont
casés ça va à cause de ça j'en sais rien
ce sera long il va eddy médy votre vie
un vrai eddie lui son vrai nom et doudou
gros ça va bien il va très très bien ce
qu'on veut mais là ça va tout ça bien
tous deux vivent ça va être le tabac
mais la fin de rihanna par jour je suis
à moins de deux paquets d'avants
ouais c'est bien conservés en bonne
santé quand ma main mais pourquoi mais
je sais pas parce que tu as pris un
moment où d'autres substances un peu
plus illicites quand même non oui mon
faux trop fragile une interview tu
disais une petite l'insee bien avant
d'aller chez guy lux comprend non mais
c'est vrai non mais enfin danger jamais
non plus dit qu'il fallait encore bien
l'allemand personnes d'ici aux jeux
personnes un sourire et l'alcool à un
moment c'était quand même à une
bouteille de chivas par jour je me
souviens - non non c'était chivas
heureusement t elle permis à l'époque
dit non quand même plus jeune je me
souviens tu te rends compte
pourquoi parce qu'avec une bouteille de
chivas par jour l'alcootest à mes yeux
les percussions de communes tu as quel
âge
qui en situe le dit avoir la bombe à 1
46 ans c'est l'âge d'une petite
interview de chez capter près la taille
la taille grande
ouais bah tu veux dire toi 23 un ton
poids 80 c'est bien bel homme moyen
s'est bâti l'équipe sébastien les plus
gros ses partisans elles sont commandées
denrées sont bien nous attends je vais
te faire sabatier oui je vous aime et à
l'est elles sont bien propre et où tu
fume pas je vous aime pas là et c'est
pour ça tu n as combien d'origine
j'en ai ma sympathie va l'appliquer 4
28 28 tu as les cheveux gras ou secs
blonds et les yeux alors bon ils sont
clairs on a dû donc tu voyais très
longtemps tu porte pas de lunettes ils
portent pas de l'anti comme 25 les
seniors
pas du tout presbytes prix astigmate que
j'ai chalco stigmates à la rédac
profession du père il était officier de
marine un divan et la mer ma mère a
donné des centres piano tout à fait
l'armée quinze jours pourquoi ils t'ont
pas gardé
non j'ai les cheveux trop longs qu'est
ce qu'il a fait c'est de rire et larmes
et sport + 2 way dorment une première
expérience sexuelle du temps souviens
assez terre dépend ce qu'on appelle
expérience sexuelle déjà tout nu avec
une période en outre personne même si a
pas pénétration situé à l'avant alors je
viens attouchements quoi j'allais dans
le foin dans le foin quel âge ça pique
ouais 12 ans 12 ans et c'est bien alors
précoce avant que les uns ces années de
la disputation consentants elle n'était
pas contente en effet sophie dessus je
me suis laissé faire certes à
traumatiser ont failli tout faire du
tout fréquence hebdomadaire des rapports
sexuels
ça vous fait rire 2 2 cette météo n'est
jamais que 18 noms 1-2 majeur recul pour
mieux se
c'est qu'en général je veux dire le
samedi soir à pointe urbain non non non
il n'y a pas de pas de mettre n'importe
quand ça peu avant une émission sans fin
et la décontracter ça fait ça fait
listings en gnl en fait ça fait du bien
coups des coups d'éclat petit coup
d'éclat oui on tire déjà je sais déjà
été violée enfin pas au point de partir
en courant mais il ya eu des tentatives
quand même oui une fois d'ailleurs ça
aboutit visité plusieurs sinon elles
étaient seules elles étaient sept à
sauter dessus
elle m'a sauté dessus oui j'utilise fr
oui parce que je voulais pas quand même
me traite de pds que tu as eu recours
dans ta vie à l'amour tarifé quoi mais
je sais jamais eu besoin de payer pour
ça pour l'instant
d'ailleurs pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
qu'il ait pas eu besoin il peut y avoir
des gens en me disant tiens cela ça
coûte ça coûte temps un appartement je
paye ça me l'autre l'envi sa pente et
bastien il paye ses chaussons jours
est ce que tu as des perversions
sexuelles
non enfin qui sont à vous à la
télévision si tu veux mais non je
comprends j'ai pas l'impression d'être
un pervers mais non on prend chose d'un
peu bcbg coince avant est ce que tu es
prêt pour faire une petite interview
check up de ses dépens bon ben on va
voir et rff
alors ton nom d'abord wolinski c'est un
vrai nom oui mais comment avec un nom
qui vient de l'est tu peux être
d'origine tunisienne
comment c'est possible parce que je suis
né à tunis d'un père polonais d'une mère
franco italienne en 1934 tas d'autres
prénoms que george david ac tou tv / non
non non jamais quand tu étais petit
personnes appelées par le maire va pas
les gee gees m'apprécient pendant très
longtemps m'appeler georgy un gentil
mais j'ai cessé de vouloir qu'on
m'appelle george hill à la mort de ma
première femme qui s'appelle comment tes
copains là tu vois avec cavanna cabu on
a du mal à ça près par les prénoms et
dans la série des surnoms ta femme
maryse elle tu appelles comme on lit non
plus à montrer un peu dans l'intimité
des gens écoutent je trouve que j'ai eu
un très joli nojaret parce que les
femmes le disent très bien et une femme
quand elle dit une femme amoureuse quand
elle dit georges un sextant du
alors ta taille j'ai un mètre 73 1 m 73
et emploie 75 kg et sur un peu plus
c'est en fait c'est le poids que
j'aimerais avoir mais là j'ai deux kilos
de trop je les ai pris en italie alors
tu es dedans maintenant dans la combien
d'origine moi je toutes mes dents réputé
leur voyage en une ou deux qui me manque
c'est vrai sur les pas de nouvelles
j'aime bien les danseuses du ventre qui
ont des dents noircies début que tu es
tu nous as les cheveux a commencé à les
perdre à quel âge
passées ces jeunes vers 11h30 en sept
ans maire de les perdre
non alors les cheveux qui reste il va
pas mal encore est-ce qu'ils sont gras
ou secs des laps de temps en temps quand
même ah oui mais là tu sais ce qu'elles
sont en pointe utilise aussi j'utilise
toujours de même un shampoing de chez
guerlain sur une île privée alors les
yeux tu es mieux pas steegmans presbytes
c'est quoi j'ai des lunettes pour voir
vient cette idée du muguet acte isolé
j'ai des lunettes monsieur des sortes de
loupe un jeu mais je me sers que pour
lire donc fait mieux qua non vous
présidez ni me up du président et quoi
alors je pars casting matt s'est pas
posé de question et frappe m'a regardé
mes invités passent jamais de questions
mais je suis pas répondre tu vois j'ai
rayé pour ça je suis posé des question
j'ai travaillé huit ans à l'humain sans
jamais poser une question il valait
mieux pas là bas
dit moi quand tu seras plus âgés tu
feras dans des implants apparemment tu
veux pas en faire mais tu feras des
liftings des machins des trucs où tu te
montrera à la télé et dans thé chauffe
un peu gros ça te dérange pas où ça te
dérange non je resterai comme je suis
non je vais pas changer ma gueule c'est
un peu incompatible avec nous le métier
d'humoriste et la distance que nous
avons sur les choses devraient changer
la réalité
il faisait quoi ton papa il était
ferronnier d'art c'est un manuel et à
maman jamais eu vraiment un métier
maintenant elle a fait beaucoup de
choses n'avaient pas vraiment un métier
à l'époque ça ne se faisait pas
tellement surtout dans les faits du nord
africaine de tunis on n'apprenait pas de
métier aussi
quant à commencer à gagner de l'argent
tu leur en a donné tout leur a fait des
cadeaux
il écoute la première fois que j'ai
gagné vraiment de l'argent c'était avec
la publicité c'est en 68 et j'avais
gagné beaucoup d'argent avec le chocolat
mars
ouais j'avais eu un gros chèque sa
première fois de ma vie que j'avais tant
de fric et tu vas savoir le plaisir que
j'ai eu à partir sur la côte d'azur et
que mes enfants aient à payer des
vacances amusé à mes parents c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est un petit check up vite
fait 1
normal après une grossesse après une
naissance tu sais toutes les questions
qui me font chier mais comme tu peux pas
imaginer en raison des fausses tout le
temps c'est qu'on vous fait pas très
commedia les mères de famille vous
arrivez à tous chers comment vous faites
pour la fois comédienne et 20000 arriver
à tout faire ce qu'ils voulaient poser
n'a ca date de naissance 5 avril 55,7
fait quel âge j'en avoir 37 raconte pas
l'histoire parce que je sais compter -
oui il vaut mieux dire son âge ouais
parce que si tu dit écoute alors ça
c'est dit moi je le dis 35 ans doute le
jour
à quoi bon puisque 35 de métier mais 70
le poids bah ça dépend à clermont sait
pas quelle journée surtout ça dépendront
pourquoi la principale maladie
je suis tout le temps malade j'ai tout
le temps des truc qui déconne mais parce
que comme je fais toujours plein de
trucs comme ça qui est extrêmement
agitée toutefois il ya plein plutôt qui
se dérèglent mais pas de grosse maladie
pour le moment je touche du bois
tu as fait ton test ah bah oui parce que
tu sais qu'on ne chasse pas que tu es
enceinte ont été faits notamment que
tranquille ça va de ce côté là ça va
ouais bon tentant le long mais
tranquille chez bull le nez a mis le nez
à nez et les mollets on est arrivé on a
du mal à faire décoller je peux aller
planquer les monos et voit pas trop le
lycée plutôt calme et a dit au début de
ma carrière je voulais le faire je vais
tout le monde me conseille de faire
raboter
non non moi j'ai toujours été
extrêmement contente de monde ici parce
que je le dis je le répète en fait t'es
pas content de quelque chose dans ton
physique qu'en sais tu as posé des
problèmes
en fait quand j'étais jeune mais
contrairement à ce que tu peux penser je
collectionnais les beaux mecs avant ton
mari mais même mon mari c'est donc
jacques a dit ça sert à rien de me faire
refaire le nez et je me suis dit mais
j'ai jamais pensé ça j'ai jamais pensé
et puis comme j'ai commencé le métier
alors là j'ai commencé à rencontrer
plein de gens qui m'ont dit vous allez
faire du cinéma et ce n'est là que vous
allez jamais arrivé tous ont la cote en
toi quand tu parle d'humiliation au tout
ça je veux dire au bout d'un moment tu
conseilles tu diras bon mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a mon avis qui les sims truc ça et
tout et puis donc tu finis puis tu te
dis tu es au début de ta keo tu dis
peut-être je ferais jamais de cinéma oui
tu vois tu étais veut voir un médecin
chirurgien esthétique pitié quand on te
fait faire des photos et une orgie de
faire la démonstration alors toi tu en
est l'exemple vivant ça c'est très
rigolo c'est que tout le contraire de
moi
hier tu vas voir ben tu vois mon nez oui
elle est où la caméra là deux faces
c'est pas mal bon deux profils c'est pas
terrible
il ya une bosse alors le mec détachement
bt parce que c'est pas le nez le
problème c'est la lèvre c'est exactement
c'est la note à la lèvre un peu courte
si on travaille ça tu vas comme tes
lèvres elle est longue
toi petit moment
un doigt mais pousse moi regarde rien
mais tu n'as pas de là dessus qu'il faut
les tours certes avec le nez qui était
bien fait rire parce qu'ils n'ont rien
dit parce que vous avez la lettre trop
qu il faisait le montant il a divisé le
montant qui revient à 10 h était pas
celle d'un saint genèse coup
au final qui descendent aussi c'est vrai
oui je sais ce que tu as dit qu'il
fallait tout refaire
donc j'ai les molettes j'ai dit ouais et
mollets oui mais la cellulite à des
conseils à donner avant l'été aux gens
dans l'est
le départ en vacances cinq critères je
connais bien problème de civisme
alors et franchement à part rien bouffer
faire du sport il n'ya rien d'autre qui
marche
cela dit mon mec est tellement beau que
quand on nous voit ensemble des fois
c'est désobligeant nouveau parce que je
vois mais qui dit mais comment mais
comment elle a fait office la vie
vachement bien votre marine je suis
assez déplaisant quoi tu vois ça veut
dire mais comment elle fait pour toi
comment tu as fait et bien il m'a
regardé puis il tombe et il est tombé
dans la vérité fut obligé de dire qu'il
est un peu miro et qu'il n'est pas ses
lunettes
mais moi je me trouve vachement bien
comme non s'échappe
on va être obligé de faire une petite
interview check up oui tu es prêt
ensuite toujours pour être comme chez le
docteur tu vas chez les scouts
alors ton nom d'abord distel liste elle
sait donc maintenant c'est le non non
mon père et de mon grand père paternel
après ton prénom c'est parce achat parce
que ce n'est pas de salsa cha ils sont
obligés d'employer un mode oui c'est pas
enfin bon c'est alexandre posément va
tout sépare mais mon père était
d'origine russe et le l'employé de
mairie n'a pas voulu parce qu'il n'y pas
de salsa cha je suis premier du nom
calendrier teddy surnom surnom autre que
sa chatte loin
pas que je sache tout 30 juin date de
naissance 1933 c'est triste et didon
alors ça veut dire que tu vas sûreté 60
ans oui c'est mon inspiration la plus
totale c'est d'arriver être le plus beau
sexagénaire de son enfance assez sur les
dix mois c'est quoi le secret alors le
secret ou un lifting non un plan non je
pense au contraire j'ai pour un garçon
je pense que c'est assez bien de 2,10 à
toi la vie mais les rides la vie mais
les cheveux blanche comme il faut les
garder c'est incroyable comme n'ai
jamais rien fait non cigarettes non hd
jamais fumé duras est connue je ne fume
pas je ne bois pas et ne trompent leur
femme sait qu'un seul défaut cimentaire
le nil est parfait
au mieux ça sera un tout neuf les dents
c'est pas de moustache mais les dans les
danses et les miennes c'est à wau tu
peux y aller les yeux sont beaux d'abord
mais c'est les miens aussi est ce que tu
vois bien très bien ça pas besoin de
lunettes si de très près ça des verrues
non j'en ai eu
alors est ce que tu as fait ton test on
teste pour le sida ah oui je les fais je
les fais on n'y a pas longtemps du reste
si tu savais vu mes antécédents jeu
match mas m'astreins tous les ans ou
tous les deux ans faire un check up
c'est tout moi tout a mal à ses sons de
synthés rue aujourd'hui
et à l'heure pendant budgétaire bien
faire qu'on paie 200 pour voir si le
métabolisme ceci et truc cela lévita
lisa ali bastien pendant combien
allons-y et ben non paper bonjour tous
et je pense que c'est c'est on est forcé
d'avoir peur maintenant parce que
parce que malheureusement ça hein ça
galope vite et ça peut arriver partout
donc faut faire attention et on doit
avoir donc les filles vous le savez il
n'y a pas de problème avec sacha michel
alors comment s'est pas vu depuis
longtemps à faire du check up vous m'en
voudrez pas oui je prends à tous dans
cette émission
les gens étaient prêts à tous dans la
voûte d'ailleurs faudrait comme je les
ai pas vus la vôtre je regarde plus la
télé j'ai tricard à ce point là vous
avez plus droit diète et puis droit de
la regarder non plus ensuite je la
regardais mais j'avoue je je je m'en
désintéresse de plus en plus bas alors
interview check up c'est un peu pénible
enfin j'espère que vous y survivrait
maintenance et polak wii prennent en
main michel oui toujours
et puis les bernard bernardelli surnom
non au pow pow pow il ya un qui m'a tu
vas voir l'intimité elle vous appelle
comment on pousse à n'ont donc pu signer
non je supporte pas quand on me donne
des surnoms de ce genre je m'en vais là
bas
par ailleurs il argué t-il on va vite
les auchan votre date de naissance
oh la la disquette 30 oh la la
ouais et les complémentaires
la retraite ça vous fait rire depuis
deux ans la retraite lieu de naissance
paris paris 16ème à choisir oui
ah bah ouais signe assignation et
beaucoup souffert des signes
astrologiques bélier vous y croyez à ça
finalement un petit peu ah oui
principales maladies en live à pâques
non non moi ça j'étais tout le temps
malade ouais je sais ce navire est soit
malade
voilà soi même
ça m'a dit au lieu d'aller chez le
psychanalyste ou faire une bonne petite
mallette elle s'assure baptisé vous avez
fait votre test quel test du sida d'ici
là oui c'est fait oui je suis négatif
c'est 50 et les danses à la l'aidant à
parce qu'on commence à m'en remettre des
fausses mais ça se voit pas trop dans le
contraire et bien faire il a deux ou
trois vous avez les cheveux gras ou sec
froid sec plutôt oui les yeux comment ça
va ben les yeux à part un peu d'allergie
jeu ça va puis j'ai des lunettes est
myope presbytes astigmate je suis
presque 13 degrés bien lafitte la gueule
profession des parents
hélas ce mon père était tout le monde
appelait ça directeurs commerciaux des
importateurs de balle il a été important
il n'a pas été importateur il est allé
se faire de la banane en afrique
hier j'ai une photo de lui et que son
casque colonial et s'épanouir et portait
hill après tempête
vous avez une enfance pauvre ou riche
bas jusqu'en 39 une enfance riche et
après 39 une enfance popeux s'est mal
passé ça s'est très mal passé vous êtes
autodidacte diplôme et un an j'ai eu mon
bac
autodidacte par tout à fait vous avez
des problèmes d'adolescence rébellion
contre les parents à bah oui parce que
je n'ai pas tellement voulu continuer
mes études et je suis parti sur la route
c'était avant les beatniks mais c'est un
peu ça c'est aussi travaillé dans des
fermes j'ai travaillé dans des usines
c'est la pêche buvait plus je vieillis
plus je trouve qu'un bond à ses quelque
chose de fort bien mais le whisky tout
ça le champagne non combien de cuite par
semaine aso ne me quitte pas avant ou
fumer je ne fume plus la petite une
pique à l'arrêt et célèbres qu'ils
avaient bon vous avez vous avez déjà
pris du haschich du 6 et j goûter 168
aux effets mais depuis ça m'a fait
beaucoup rire près et après j'ai trouvé
qu'un beaujolais c'était bien plus
agréable et ça me fait beaucoup plus
d'effet les c'est autre chose que cas et
non non vraiment j'ai horreur de tout ce
qui habille nos cerveaux
les lsd toutes ces choses là où je
trouve terrible si si j'ai un outil
c'est mon cerveau alors labit mecque des
drogues ont tous les week-ends
d'ormesson c'est donc tu t'arrêtes avec
des hommes comme on se connaît pas bien
on va faire une interview check up et
quand on aura fini la table ou check up
on se connaîtra très bientôt lui quel
bonheur
ton nom est vite passé ton prénom
leclerc leclerc c'est en vrai nom est le
c est le rcq parce que c'est qc belge
abanda car il croyait pas du tout que
c'était pour ça tu as des surnoms
d'abord non ma fille m'appelle nanane
bon c'est tout temps julie t'appelles
comment lit il m'appelle pas parce que
j'ai pas du thé jules t'appelles comment
alors bye mavel pas une télé de temps en
temps mais vous êtes adepte des
naissances c'est déjà beaucoup
je sais je sais je n'ai jamais caché
avoir de la secousse et mater la date de
naissance de 4,58 non j'ai eu 41 ans je
sais que je les fais largement la télé
ça esquinte pas mal mais bon
non mais j'ai pas de problème à ce
niveau là je me sens bien
weight à l'heure je ne sais pas si vous
me sentais bien
die en largeur
alors non à la deuxième question mais je
sais pas 163 je parlais en cm ton point
alors ça ça va rien qu'au taux est
variable
je suis fâchée avec ma valence depuis un
mois oui ça c'est un sujet tabou tour de
poitrine ça c'est pas tabou du tout
parce que mes consoeurs ce soir les
montres et les leurres général en chef
le fallait on va faire un petit tour
dans quoi moi j'ai un peu camouflée
alors bon lorsque dans les 90 jours 10
81 souffle à monsieur connaissait en en
90 ans quel bonheur dans les baies je
pense combien le bâton de bois 3 90 à
tiennent dans la main d'un honnête homme
s'est concocté fait de la prison 90 ça
tient dans la main dans un monde à moi
ça dépend sur sa tout dépend du soutien
gorge
ouais ya des jours où 100 et des jours
avec on avait commencé avec 66 mais avec
le soutien gorge moi je parle là ce soir
c'est à 18,92 fallait qu'on les voit
mieux
ça dépend par des soutiens gorge alors
et puis à d'autrefois ou au contraire je
les montre absolument pas la lie à rien
c'est l'autoroute c'est tout droit le
nez tomber tu as fait refaire d'origine
en cependant tu es d'origine les dangers
au regret de vous le dire tout et
d'original dans aussi oui le cheveu gras
ou sait qu on sait qu abominable lab les
téléspectateurs ont pu le constater
depuis longtemps mais ils m'ont pardonné
aussi longtemps les yeux alors tu as tes
yeux formidable fines de claire numéro 9
c'est mieux l'enterrer steegmans a rien
sans rien de hausse et des dix disent
oui plus que ça même j'ai une vision
plus importante que la moyenne
ah bon tu vois quoi la exemple que nous
on voit qu'à genevois de la nuit
non mais je vois dire que les gens dicte
à l'ope nyctalope oui mais pas prêt ce
budget un groupe tu as des signes
particuliers de tiger mais en fait je
n'ai rien de particulier je me demande
même ce que je fais dans ce métier je
n'ai absolument
je suis quelqu'un de très banal en fait
t'as pas de grain de beauté des rues de
la cicatrice de tatouages manon non mais
c'est bien mais techno chasse est nickel
je crois qu'après cette décision mais
j'espère donc j'attends gauche à droite
hier droitière bêtement une enfance
pauvre ou riche je dirais moyenne ces
dits pauvres aura laissé dirige ce sera
pas vrai mais française genre chez la
toute petite fille de français moyens
avec un papa une maman que j'adore et
que j'embrasse d'ailleurs très fort oui
tiens je peux c'est comme à tournez
manège exactement c'est pareil
finalement c'est la télévision des
autodidactes ou diplômés ont des mots
tout simples justement il est super le
candidat du parti n'est pas grossier
livre il ya vraiment infiniment de
talent ça tire et gentille non non
autodidacte mais un peu diplômés quand
j'ai eu mon bac à 16 ans vous quand même
hein quand même j'ai mon brevet de
pilote d'avion que j'ai eu à l'âge de 19
ans licence de [ __ ] qu'elle ait eu à
non c'est à dire de france qui me tient
le plus à coeur et leur est bon c'est
bon la télévision c'est venu j'ai appris
sur le tas comme j'ai dit au début de
l'émission et c'est beaucoup de travail
est-ce que prenant un mot simple oui
lequel sont des emplois maison ça c'est
cochon ça ah bon d'accord donc tu sais
ce que ça veut dire
j'en ai vaguement entendu parler
qu'arthur lui savait pas ce monsieur a
oui non je sais maison non plus j'ai une
question que je laisse pas de poser ya
clics via que la grèce réponses qui sont
un disque est bon à jeter à la pause
alors oui vas-y fréquences hebdomadaires
des rapports sexuels
là ça t'étonne rien hebdomadaire tu veux
dire quotidien combien de fois par la
question était mal pour bien de madère
c'est une semaine
on reprend tout à zéro
justement l'art il faut que je fasse une
multiplication par 7 ouais parce que
aide de modèles 7 jours il faut que je
multiplie par sept
or 3 x 7 21 21 on applaudit et une
minorité
tournant le vrai jeune k christophe t
prénom tous christophe patrick gérard où
tu es sûrement quand tu étais petit
titoff crise tout comme ça avec ma mère
gros poussin écrit ouais tu y trouves
ton âge 30 ans bataille entre mad 80 et
1 mètre 81 salue toujours un ennemi
temps poids mon poids entre eux entre 80
et 81 81 deux longueurs de la [ __ ] la
moyenne nationale est à combien la
moyenne nationale est à 18 19
c'est vrai ah ouais donc toi avec ton 23
tu es une star ouais je pense que je
suis c'est bien mais c'est dans quel
pays ça 18 19
c'est une particulier c'est une
particulier je suis dessus de la moyenne
nationale des opérations
oui justement on va rester sur ça sur le
l'opération non mais j'ai g31 donc j'ai
quand même une
à combien tu as drame et vine 3 aussi et
voilà
et donc c'est ce qui m'a permis de ne
pas faire mon service me connaître en
gueule aussi ça m'a beaucoup gêné ça me
gêne beaucoup au quotidien des
cicatrices
là c'est mon frère en fait parce qu'on
est petit avec des robes de chambre
rouge et je suis arrivé il a éveillé il
rêvait d'être toréador alors de toréador
il fallait bien qu'ils aient un mec face
au taureau moi je m appuie le radiateur
botton adorait m'avait bien des
tatouages des verrues d'une grande
beauté
une verrue alors parler d'amour l'amour
en pleine lumière dans la pénombre
ça dépend alors en pleine lumière en
pleine lumière si ya pas de virus en
pleine lumière d'accord combien de fois
par semaine c'est quoi la moyenne
nationale
quoi une fois tu es tranquille
une fois par semaine un maillot national
je suis
au dessus de la moyenne nationale
l'alcool la drogue
non c'est pas bien d'ailleurs je peux en
profiter
bon sens me dis moi tu fais pas ça c'est
du message c'est pas bien la drogue
est-ce que vous devenez facilement
évitables après quelques heures passées
devant la télévision devant moi je
regarde la télé beaucoup la nuit en fait
donc je chaque fois c'est un peu de la
récup je vois une émission en
rediffusion j'insinue
bon alors on coucher vous n'avez jamais
la sensation d'avoir comme un oeuf
- c'est dans le plexus solaire enfin
dans le plexus
est-ce que vous être des prises de sang
immédiatement après une piqûre d'insecte
non c'est plutôt la saq qui devrait
aller à faire un jeu blanc
est ce que est ce que tu te vous avez
des vertiges accompagnée de douleurs
chroniques
non non non des aphtes jamais norway ça
m'arrive excuse et des petits points
blancs devant les yeux ou alors au bout
du sexe des petits trucs que tu viens de
voir est ce que ça vous arrive
non non non mais pourquoi tu te fais du
souci tu veux savoir c'était lui je
crois que tu as d'appeler au bâtiment
dans les débats
mais merci quelqu'un l'a portée avant
moi ça m'a annoncé la matière alors
l'odeur ou alors c'est moi mes filles
c'est la raison pour laquelle tu vas
avoir droit à l'interview quelqu'un
[Musique]
bon alors le nom le connaissez darmon le
prénom c'est gérard l'âge 55
voilà comme moi année érotique un
érotique à la taille de quoi non
question ces cas là c'est ty pris 81,80
le poids 75 bravo très bien très bien
conservés gérard darmon comme un de ces
femmes ainsi vous bruno j'ai perdu 15
kilos et vous êtes vraiment vraiment pas
mal et on sait rien c'est le cancer ou
sais c'est le cancer ou c'est agnès qui
vous sert non non non c'est juste que
quand tu te retrouves avec un bide comme
ça tu dis où j'arrête ou je continue moi
j'ai décidé d'arrêter vote à raison de
cette façade va très bien la taille du
sexe gérard je sais que c'est une
question qui vous obsède un petit je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure 80
[Musique]
donc il y en a qui ont des cartes de
bons clients ouais bon repos en plus
parce que les rênes mais il sait pas où
la loge et après c'est à vous gênez non
quand même pour parler non pas bien fait
ça veulent sortir
attention les se déplie là alors
sérieusement cette opération pour
doubler la taille de votre pénis c'est
ça s'est bien passé
oui ça c'est on va dire que c'est
finalement ça s'est bien passé c'était
compliqué quand je dirais que compliqué
mais on passe pas directement de 2,2 de
l'anah l'éléphant comme ça et l art
problèmes d'érection on en reparle plus
là c'est fini c'est fini c'est un plus
auquel deux ailes quand même oui on
était inquiet je me demande ça a duré
quand même 5 6 ans si c'était vous est
vachement intimes les cheveux ça va ça
va non mais c'est une couleur pas du
tout nouveau centre et ceci malgré les
maigres biens cette taille des doigts et
encore tu veux rester une couille pour
brawn on est bon les yeux alors est ce
qu'on peut dire ma fiche là les cheveux
ça ou une couleur les yeux vous pouvez
lire ma chif
une séance amour plus qui se faire
et vos films
c'est marrant parce que je le trouve
meilleur depuis que vous avez changé de
lunettes c'est parce que vous vous lisez
les scénarii maintenant je dis oui
d'abord il fallait d'abord apprendre à
la wii c'est ça il fallait apprendre à
lire une fenêtre et maintenant je vois
là et c'est comme ça qu'on fait le coeur
des hommes
l'année prochaine il les comprend et
encore et encore il n'avait pas les
jambes un peu lourdes en fin de journée
non c'est ça peut m'arriver je me méfie
fait vrai pourquoi kwakwa cas d'exercice
à 1 mètre 80 ça doit pas être est ce que
vous pouvez me tirait la langue et faire
ah oui bien sûr mais pas à n est pas
trop charger soir ça va j'ai fait quoi
hier soir qu'est-ce que j'ai fait hier
soir maison à maison va oui c'est pour
ça il sait 18 chars 10 ans oui mais
auront tranquille tranquille gauche ça
se voit sur la langue
oui elle est bien rose aujourd'hui oui
d'habitude les jaunes cris fusent au
niveau des cicatrices de la vie vous en
êtes où j'ai rarement
oui oui
ça va elle sont elles font elles font
pas trop mal être sont bien fermés il y
en a quelques-unes un peu plus sensibles
que d'autres mais tout va bien ça va
j'attendais prochaine et les blessures
intérieures les blessures intérieures
les blessures intérêt vu que ça devient
un peu celui ci victor de la longueur de
la vie n'aurait pas du tout je remercie
[Musique]
dors bernard kouchner vous êtes chez le
docteur ardisson 30 oct bonjour je vous
ai pas fait attendre ça va non ça va
bien qu'est ce qui vous donne envie de
vomir dans le monde actuel le mensonge
qu'est ce qui vous fait mal au coeur
dans le monde actuel la pression en
france qu'est ce qui vous donne mal à la
tête
la vie quotidienne était lié au long je
voyais à venir la violence
qu'est ce qui vous donne des boutons
dans le milieu politique
la même chose un ulcère je pose pas la
question c'est pareil ah non un succès
ça fait mal alors faites comme un nul
c'est alors dans le milieu politique
aujourd'hui en france cette façon de
croire que quand une idée vient de
l'autre quand elle est forcément mauvais
personne n'y croit et pourtant on fait
toujours de céder à cette espèce de
guerre civile oui je crois que ça c'est
dommageable pour le pays et pour
l'estomac et pas thomas particulier mais
pour le pays surtout quelle femme
politique vous donne la fière
aujourd'hui en france roselyne bachelot
ah oui et vous excite
non je les aime bien ah oui j'ai des
convictions
pourquoi vous l'aimez bien parce que je
les aime bien je la trouve sympathique
et france elle est marrante qui fait le
plus de gaffe c'est ça non non non pas
du tout moi je veux bien non je trouve
absolument entière primesautière a
merveilleusement habiller leurs vives
c'est trop je suis déjà et je non non
non je tiens à ce que je compte de
compliments tu le compliment tout ça
bien habillé la légende et gris a marqué
l'injustice aujourd'hui en france vous
fait vraiment mal au cul je crois que
cette mesure qui consiste à donner moins
d'argent aux jeunes femmes ont sans fin
pour la première naissance ou jeunes
femmes enceintes qui ont un besoin terry
parce qu'elles n'ont pas de ressources
me paraît particulièrement inappropriés
et scandaleuse voilà bah écoutez le
check up est terminée ça va ça va là bas
ça va vous voulez que je vous prescrive
un peu de viagra comme la dernière fois
non mais il m'a prescrit un truc comme
ça va tu l'avais je n'ai pas pris fait
partie diot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel est l'homme politique qui vous
donne des boutons non paris alors qu'ils
venaient de tomber d'accord pas assez
d'importance
qu'est ce qui vous fait vomir dans le
cinéma américain aujourd'hui et se met à
poil tout ce qui se montre un descriptif
de ne pas la comprendre quel est le
comique américain aujourd'hui qui vous
donne de la fièvre
il ya ce degré jing yu gi oh sujet de
quelques milk américain voudriez vous
être amnésique n'ont pas dit non mais je
suis très heureux je ne vous rendez vous
david et femmes rentrer la dernière fois
que votre coeur s'est arrêté de battre
c'était pour qui pour moi il fait madore
pour sa femme et sa fille emerson ayant
sun
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois que vous avez eu des
larmes dans les yeux de simone et wok
meilleur tour réveillé tout ça vous fait
mal quand vous voyez des jeunes qui
connaissent pas vos films n'ont pas
d'état et quand on vous prend pour
l'animateur du téléthon ça vous fait de
la peine ouais pourquoi tu dis tu ailles
abandonne 2 qu'à l'automne mais j'ai
fait le téléthon à la braise one by one
nine hundred million d'albums et gégé
j'ai ramassé à bignon 900 millions de
dollars
oui
soler qui s'est invitée dès brins gros
donc ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
moi j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
ça vous fait mal quand vous réalisez que
beaucoup de vos amis sont morts non ap
bonnes vacances et avec quoi ce qu'une
fois ue ok ok i'm itno j'ai besoin de
savoir h dans au stop de chant aaa
pendant que d'autres cho oyu trying to
get me to be nasri est ce que tu essaies
de me vendre mauvais non would you like
to me a sign up beach est ce que tu
voudrais que ce soit au canada mais je
ne peux pas faire ça dans 3o l'audience
or about jane c'est pour ça que tout me
répond selon les mêmes i-care j'aime je
peux je prends soin des gîtes du web et
des niayes can't make the world oif
je fais tout ce que je peux croyez marie
aubry
goodman je suis un homme très beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous donne ma tête
aujourd'hui dans la médecine la prise en
charge de la pauvreté de la misère
ouais qu'est-ce qui vous filent un
ulcère quand vous voyez bosser les
médecins libéraux
pas grand chose sauf quand finalement un
certain nombre exerce une médecine qui
n'est pas prouvé scientifiquement
ouais qu'est ce qui vous fait vomir aux
urgences c'est vraiment la détresse
humaine qu'elle soit physique ou
psychologique qu'est ce qui vous fait
mal au coeur quand vous voyez la
sécurité sociale c'est surtout ouais
c'est surtout quand j'ai eu quand je
suis allé voir au sri lanka après le
tsunami de voir la richesse de notre
pays qu'on a qu'on a peut-être tendance
à oublier un ouais
quelle minute de la santé vous a donné
le plus de boutons boutons non non non
j'ai jamais nombre de l'indifférence oui
deux boutons non même mater vous a
jamais donné de temps mais je n'ai rien
contre les personnes mattei douste blazy
xavier bertrand kouchner c'est des
personnalités que c'était à moi c'est
les fonctions c'est à dire que c'est
huit ministres 1
c'est donc c'est à lui que revient la
charge que tout un chacun ou l'histoire
de notre pays a fait qu'on est dans une
république qu'il est en charge du
domaine politique donc il est redevable
de quelque chose à l'égard de la
population et de l'égalité qui est
marqué sur tous les fronts
sur quelle période de votre vie
aimeriez-vous être amnésique
oh la vache
ça c'est un check up peut-être
maintenant si tout est maintenant ouais
c'est pas bien tu peux bien trop
médiatisée c'est pas assez pas le fait
d'être médiatisé c'est le fait que
écoutez ce qui est épouvantable quand
vous êtes un peu dans le regard des
objectifs c'est que d'autres utilisent
que vous dites pour le détourner de son
sens premier et l'utiliser à d'autres
fins
et vous vous sentez c'est pas facile à
c'est pas facile à porter il ya des
soirs c'est plus dur que d'autres way
qu'est-ce qui vous démange en politique
en ce moment écoutez c'est l'europe
je crois que je crois qu'il faut
absolument récupérer faut pas que
l'europe s'en aille
pourquoi dimanche votée c'est très
important à chaque fois mais c'est vrai
pourtant way pensez-y dimanche venu
serait tué samedi tuant passe pour
écouter votre visite et énergique acquis
en ce moment à moi et est la dernière
fois que votre coeur s'est arrêté de
battre c'était pour qui pour l'instant
non mais nous sommes les meilleurs allez
une dernière en politique j'ai trouvé le
cul avec ses idées jamais personne n'a
trouvé le cul
comme j'avais l'air très en forme jack
ça va la santé excellent excellent c'est
vrai je fais quelques envieux
un parmi mes petits camarades fait ce
qu'on prend comme faire un petit
interlude check up
jack qu'est ce qui vous rend malade
quand vous venez à la télé le trac
oh ben ça va mieux là quelques instants
beauvais ouais
qu'est ce qui vous donne ma la tête
aujourd'hui dans les discours de jacques
chirac
un sorte de vide 1
mais l'homme vaut parfois mieux que ses
discours
qu'est ce qui vous fait vomir dans le
gouvernement de villepin actuellement
l'art du mensonge
qu'est ce qui vous fait mal au coeur
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez sarkozy
sa voix de karcher
qu'est ce qui vous fait vous arracher
les cheveux au ps aujourd'hui ce que je
manque de cheveux non pas vous qu'est-ce
qui vous filent un ulcère
conventionnelle de 20 heures sur tf1 le
l'enfilade de kata quel homme politique
vous donne le plus de boutons pas un
homme politique c'est ce régime
politique dans lequel nous vivons qui me
donne beaucoup de boutons et c'est
pourquoi il faut le changer qu'est-ce
qui vous démange en ce moment l' envie
de me battre et de gagner la dernière
fois que votre coeur s'est arrêté de
battre c'était pour qu'ils vont monique
à venir qu'est ce qui vous a mis la
fillette pour la dernière fois
gilberto gil 20 14 juillet place de la
bastille qu'est-ce que vous prenez comme
excitant dans la vie le boulot le
travail je me shoote au travail un peu
de cocaïne quand même pas besoin de
travailler
je suis un drogué du boulot à quelle
idée êtes-vous allergique à tout ce qui
porte atteinte à la dignité humaine
quel chanteur de charme au fil du
diabète à ses mauvaises heures dominique
de villepin qu'est ce que vous entendez
moins bien vieilli sans pardon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus